a lot of these altcoins that PP really
hard and you get those 100x returns
they're going to die out the SEC is
going to crush that the more credible
Bitcoin is becoming because of the spot
ETF it's going to be less volatile and
it's actually going to even itself out
these buor runs may not really exist So
Much Anymore Bitcoin could turn into the
next gold right the digital gold do we
see that type of volatility with gold we
don't see that with gold the more
Bitcoin and ethereum have credibility
have backing from the SEC institutions
like Black Rock the more stable these
assets are going to become we're not
going to see these returns anymore I
really believe what we've seen over the
last 10 years it's like a once in A-
lifetime phenomenon it's like a once in
a generation phenomenon and we are so
lucky that we've got to experience it
this is not going to last forever and
you know we've had a slight pullback and
I'd say over the next few weeks before
the Haring that is the time to get into
Bitcoin and ethereum because this could
be your very last ball run